bonsoir marc lavergne merci beaucoup à
voir avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord on a entendu ces soudaines et
c'est l'intérêt du soudan finalement de
signer cet accord pourquoi quel intérêt
à l'eau soudan alors qu'ils étaient
plutôt réticents à le faire oui mais
c'est très pragmatique le soudan est un
pays qui est aujourd'hui à genoux un la
monnaie s'est effondré l'économie tout
entière est à l'arrêt il n'y a plus de
l'électricité il n'y a plus de pétrole
il n'y a plus rien à manger
donc je pense que depuis maintenant un
an que ce régime de transition
démocratique a été mis en place
beaucoup de temps a été perdu et
finalement je pense que les américains
ont augmenté la pression sur le soudan
jusqu'à ce que le soudan soit contraint
de lâcher un
alors c'est un accord qui est
pragmatique effectivement parce que on
peut penser que il va permettre aux
souvent d'avoir accès à des financements
internationaux et peut-être à des
investissements israéliens comme ça a
été rappelé par benjamin netanyahu mais
ces investissements israéliens ne sont
pas là pour faire le bonheur des
soudanais mais pour exploiter les
exploiter les richesses du pays
donc c'est ça qui intéresse un peu la
communauté internationale en revanche du
côté soudanais la pilule est un peu amer
parce que c'est toujours humiliant
d'être obligé de signer un traité avec
le pistolet sur la tempe un an profitant
de la vulnérabilité du soudan à l'heure
actuelle encore une fois cette
vulnérabilité qui a été provoquée par
par la tente
et puis il ya une sorte d'injustice dans
la mesure où le soudan doit payer pour
des crimes qui ont été commis par
d'autres c'est à dire par oussama ben
laden al qaïda à une époque où ce
gouvernement
évidemment n'était pas en place ce
gouvernement a justement fait tomber
ceux qui étaient les responsables de cet
accord encore encore qu' on puisse
discuter puisque le le chef le président
du conseil de souveraineté le général
torhane était le numéro 2 d'omar el
béchir
donc on a dans l'état profond soudanais
et encore aujourd'hui dans la classe
politique dirigeante des gens qui ont
été coupables de ces crimes et qui sont
aujourd'hui tout à fait en osmose avec
israël avec les pays du golfe avec les
états unis
c'est un accord qui n'auraient pas pu se
faire sous sous un omar el-béchir cc
symbolique aussi le fait que ce
gouvernement de transition un signe cet
accord avec israël sous le patronage en
tout cas de donald trump pour lui c'est
une victoire diplomatique les états unis
retire le soudan de la liste des pays
terroristes qu'est ce que ça implique va
écouter dans le timing déjà on aurait pu
penser que cet accord aboutisse du temps
normal béchir puisqu'on aura le plaisir
déjà deux 2012 a cessé ses relations
avec l'iran qu'il a après rejoint la
coalition occidentale et arabes
oui et mène et donc il ya eu beaucoup de
pas qui ont été franchies par le régime
précédent pour se rapprocher de la
communauté internationale et et obtenir
des financements américains
alors aujourd'hui le timing évidemment
il a un rapport avec l'élection
présidentielle aux états unis je pense
que c'est donald trump qui a fait le
forcing pour pouvoir annoncer avec
beaucoup d'éclat
une victoire qui n'est pas finalement
ch'ti importante que ça puisque donc le
soudan n'est pas un pays hostiles aux
etats-unis loin de là il faut rappeler
que le premier ministre abdallah doc est
un cadre important de la banque mondiale
la banque mondiale qui dépend des états
unis donc il n'y a pas là quelque chose
de bouleversant
c'est plutôt une mise en scène à
laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui en
disant c'est un pays arabe
c'est un pays ennemi d'israël qui se
rallie finalement à une sorte de
realpolitik pour obtenir des subsides et
et une aide au développement
en réalité je crois que là c'est à la
fois un netanyahou et rome qui sont dans
des positions politiques difficiles qui
mettent en avant met en scène cette
signature d'un accord avec un pays qui
n'a
vraiment à proprement parler jamais
alimenté le front anti israël c'est un
pays arabe certes mais c'est aussi un
pays africain qui n'a pas la même
proximité avec israël ou avec la
palestine que d'autres pays du premier
cercle
merci beaucoup marc lavergne d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france